[Música]
y seguimos hablando de chile donde el
abogado ultraderechista de 55 años jose
antonio casi el diputado izquierdista
gabriel boric irán a una segunda vuelta
electoral luego de que ayer domingo
ninguno superar el 50 por ciento de los
sufragios requeridos para así ganar la
presidencia en la primera vuelta cast
obtuvo el 27 punto 91 por ciento de los
votos y boric el 25 punto 83 por ciento
de los sufragios con este resultado
entonces ambos candidatos pasan al
balotaje del próximo 19 de diciembre la
jornada registró una alta participación
de los 15 millones de ciudadanos de una
población de 19 millones de habitantes
llamados a las urnas para así elegir al
sucesor del mandatario saliente el
conservador sebastián piñera también
renovar renovar totalmente la cámara de
diputados y parcialmente el senado para
analizar entonces lo que pasó ayer en
chile- quiero saludar en este momento a
nuestro primer invitado del día ls
carlos cantero doctor en sociología y
conferencista carlos muy buen día
gracias entonces por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 chile
entre la posibilidad del gobierno más
derechista desde pinochet o el más
izquierdista desde allende le pregunto
cuáles son los motivos de semejante
polarización en ese país
yo diría que hay una mala lectura a
nivel internacional de lo que está
ocurriendo en chile lo que hay lo que
ocurre es que la política tradicional
que correspondió a la sociedad
industrial a la sociedad postmoderna ha
colapsado
atacaron índices del orden del 5 al 7 al
8 por ciento de votación en los partidos
que eran hegemónicos tanto en la
izquierda como en la derecha y en
consecuencia que lo que ha ocurrido
pareciera ser una polarización pero en
realidad lo que está dando como señal la
ciudadanía es que no quiere más gente
tibia
acomodaticia políticamente correcta
diciendo las cosas bonitas pero sin
hacer lo que tiene que hacer la política
que es atender a las demandas de la
ciudadanía es decir responder a la
soberanía del pueblo lo que ha habido es
un tapaboca llamando a que la democracia
cumpla el rol que le corresponde y
pidiéndole a la política que ejerza lo
que es
dictación de políticas públicas es decir
cautelar el bien común hay una lectura
bastante distinta en realidad en lo que
está ocurriendo en la ciudadanía chilena
y de hecho los candidatos noches los
leyeron muy muy claramente porque ambos
que parecían estar muy polarizados
anoche eran francamente
apóstoles de la paz apóstoles de la
unidad y eso es lo que la gente en
definitiva está viviendo la gente lo que
quiere que primero le den participación
y en segundo lugar que se responda a los
requerimientos que la ciudadanía quiere
dicho de otra manera a la izquierda le
dijeron queremos efectivamente cambio
pero no queremos ni destrozos ni
violencia ni enfrentamiento y a la
derecha que le dijeron que iremos
mercados y señores queremos mercado pero
con equidad con respeto a la ciudadanía
entregándole redistribución de los
ingresos eso es en esencia la síntesis
de lo que ha venido ocurriendo en el día
de ayer
si digamos carlos entonces que fue se
puede dar una lectura de un hartazgo de
la ciudadanía por los partidos
tradicionales y por eso entonces vimos
los resultados al que vimos ayer ahora
luego del estallido social de
llega la extrema derecha en un el primer
puesto no para esta segunda vuelta el 19
de diciembre porque ocurrió esto
bueno porque en la elección anterior
hace un año atrás para efecto de elegir
a la convención constituyente la
ciudadanía le dio una aplastante mayoría
aplastante 80% del electorado votó por
la izquierda y la izquierda no supo leer
con moderación y poco con ponderación
esta situación y no fue clara respecto
de la violencia no fue clara respecto de
la confrontación no fue clara respecto
de los saqueos que había cada vez que se
movilizaban y los destrozos los que
quedaban las ciudades no hubo claridad
respecto de aquello y eso terminó
molestando a la ciudadanía y ahora un
año después
resulta que tampoco esto se puede
interpretar
como un gran triunfo del neoliberalismo
no no no no ni tampoco de la
ultraderecha ustedes a poco andar se
darán cuenta que el candidato de la
izquierda lo único que tiene que hacer
ahora es moverse al centro para
desplazar mayoría hacia su sector y el
de la cee derecha va a tener que parar
también cada día más al centro y con
mayor prudencia y mayor moderación si
quiere efectivamente obtener un buen
dividendo político de tal manera que yo
diría en definitiva la ciudadanía lo que
ha dicho es que en este nuevo contexto
de sociedad no hay esa ideologismo
tradicional sino que hay un pragmatismo
si usted me da paz usted me da
tranquilidad nosotros estamos dispuestos
a apoyar si sea usted es el pie
izquierdo sea usted de centroderecha te
acabo el ideologismo en la política
tradicional en la sociedad chilena y
esto me parece muy interesante porque
hemos sido bastante pioneros tanto del
neoliberalismo como después de echar
fuera el neoliberalismo y predictivo que
existe en realidad mayor equilibrio
mayor prudencia es que volva yo diría
que hay un movimiento de
renacimiento de los valores
tradicionales de la política y haremos
política al servicio de la gente y al
servicio del bien común porque la
política durante los últimos 20 o 30
años ha estado al servicio de grupos
pequeños y eso la gente lo está
repudiando ahora carlos usted si creen
que estos dos candidatos se pueden ir al
centro para lograr la mayoría de los
votantes que podemos ver que pudiera
pasar en el balotaje del 19 de diciembre
estaría liderando todavía cast o boric
se puede acercar más a la presidencia
estructuralmente la campaña de gas es
mucho más sólida con una persona más
estable y mucho más cercana al modelo
tradicional que existió en chile sea
bastante más neoliberal para decirlo con
claridad en la al centroizquierda vemos
un movimiento con un candidato más débil
con un candidato con un discurso menos
estructurado y con soluciones que
todavía no están poco claras por el
tironeo fundamentalmente de los sectores
más radicales refundacionales de la
sociedad chilena entonces de hecho
anoche polis le hablaba a su cliente
diciéndole escuchemos a los que no
votaron por nosotros no nos escuchamos
nosotros escuchamos a los otros que no
quisieran estar con nosotros y lo propio
hacía también el candidato cash y siendo
un cercana mos que efectivamente gana se
ganó pero hay un porcentaje muy alto de
gente mira en la convencional del año
pasado
sólo el 20 por ciento de los chilenos
concurrió a votar repito que cada 100
personas que tenían derecho a elegir 80
no fueron a votar y sólo los 20 que
hicieron la asamblea contra la
convención constituyendo
la situación cambió tampoco es una
panacea pero por lo menos se aproxima a
la mitad de las personas que van a votar
y eso ya es un buen in y un buen
indicador de que la democracia se está
empezando a recuperar y que la política
está empezando a entender que está para
atender bienes públicos equilibrio en la
distribución del ingreso y no seguir
hablando de grandes cifras de
crecimiento económico pero con la gente
con muchas necesidades y con posibles
pues carlos entonces todo puede pasar en
el balotaje chileno el próximo 19
diciembre ya tenemos a los dos
candidatos quienes aspiran entonces a la
presidencia del país para suceder al
conservador sebastián piñera vamos a ver
qué pasa gracias por su tiempo entonces
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 y que tenga usted
un muy feliz resto de día
muchas gracias faltó un comentario
increíble que es que había ganado esta
primera vuelta estás teniendo uno de los
gobiernos de peor evaluación y muy
cercano ideológicamente a él y sin
embargo aún así previó este escenario
precisamente porque la izquierda no supo
leer adecuadas y que los plazos muchas
gracias tablón